[music playing]
MICHAEL: Russian
Orthodox Christianity
runs deep within the Night
Wolves motorcycle club.
They even have their
own bike riding monk,
a chaplain called Father Guriy.
How can I resist?
I have to meet him.
Oh, Father Guriy himself.
Ah, thank you for having us.
Another step to understanding
this new Russian vision.
I meet him here at
Lavra, outside of Moscow.
Lavra is a holy Russian
Orthodox Christian
enclave of cathedrals
and monasteries,
akin to a mini-Vatican.
So do you ride, Father?
Yes.
Really?
What bike do you ride?
One of your first
rides, and Surgeon
saw him, and said
that's what we need.
[laughter]
The Night Wolves-- they
were trying to find something,
and they found it.
Found it.
[choir singing]
MICHAEL: If I'm
trying to understand
the Russian identity, then
one must also understand
Russian Orthodox Christianity.
[choir singing]
Every book, every
historical period--
it was based on the--
You see-- you can see the
church, the role of the faith.
This has been incredible.
This has really helped
my understanding.